over the past few years in machine
learning we've seen dramatic progress in
the field of generative models and while
there are a lot of different flavors of
these generative models in this video I
want to talk specifically about one
model called the generative adversarial
Network or in short gap now gans were
first invented by Ian Goodfellow in 2014
and since then these models have seen an
incredible burst of research
improvements and applications and one of
the coolest things about Ganz is that
you can take the underlying architecture
but you can train the model on any data
set that you want so most famously the
researchers at Nvidia have trained these
models to generate faces leading to the
popular website this person does not
exist calm but you can take the same
underlying model and you can train this
on anything that you want I mean you
could train it on cats for example or on
cars or what about bedrooms anything you
have in terms of an image data set you
can use it to train this generative
model and because most of these
generative models are open sourced by
their creators a lot of nifty people on
the internet have trained their own
models on a variety of data sets like
this one for example to generate anime
faces or this one which generates album
cover art or this one that I personally
trained on Google Earth satellite images
needless to say that training your own
generative model can be a lot of fun but
that's not everything it turns out that
when you train a generative model on a
data set which is by the way a fully
unsupervised process because you're not
using any labels well it turns out that
these models actually discover the
underlying structure in that data set
and once the model has discovered this
structure you can actually start using
and exploiting that to do a variety of
pretty cool things so in this video I
want to give you an overview of what you
can actually do with the latent space of
a generative model once it has been
trained on a particular data set have
you ever wanted to see what you would
look like as part of the opposite gender
or what about playing with the
barack obama or making emilia clark
smile well in this video i will show you
how to play with a latent space of the
most powerful generative models that we
have available today and not only that
this video comes with a complete ipython
notebook
so everything we'll be doing in this
video you can do for yourself on any
image that you want are you ready to
dive in deep my name is andrew and
welcome to archive insights ok i'll
start with a quick overview of
everything we'll be seeing in this video
so initially i'm going to do a quick
introduction to generative adversarial
networks for the people who don't have a
lot of prior experience with this topic
well then do a five-minute technical
deep dive on the objective function that
is actually optimized when you train one
of these Gatz will then go and look at
some of the state-of-the-art techniques
that people often use in these
generative models and that allowed them
to actually generate such beautiful and
high-quality images and then the rest of
this video is going to cover how you can
actually use the latent space to
manipulate any image that you want
alright so the idea behind guns is
pretty simple but it's also very
beautiful so in essence what we have is
two neural networks we have the
generator and we have the discriminator
the generator is in charge of doing the
following it gets a randomly sampled
noise vector as an input in most cases
we'll sample from a Gaussian
distribution we take that noise vector
and we input it into the neural network
we you know follow through a bunch of
convolutional layers and at the end we
have an image this image is then fed to
a second neural network the
discriminator and the discriminator has
one job it needs to look at an image and
decide whether that image comes from the
actual data set the real images that
were training on or whether that image
came from the generator and is thus a
fake image
and because we are you know controlling
the training process we have the label
we know for each image that we feed to
the discriminator whether that image was
a real one coming from the beta set or a
fake image coming from the generator and
by using this label we can basically
back propagate a training loss through
this discriminator network in order to
make it better but the nice thing is
that this generator network itself is
also a fully differentiable neural
network so if we stick these two
networks back-to-back we can actually
back propagate the learning signal
through this entire model pipeline and
this way we can update with the same
single loss function we can update both
the discriminator and the generator
network until they both get really
really good at their job so the most
important trick in this pipeline is to
make sure that both these networks are
well balanced during training so that no
one of them gets the upper hand and if
you manage to do so and you train it for
long enough then eventually what you'll
have is a generator that has been
learning from the feedback of this
discriminator network and can eventually
you know manage to generate images that
look very very similar to the data set
we've been training on okay so with that
general introduction of the idea behind
ganz let's do a 5-minute technical deep
dive on the objective function that is
used while training so the be clear I'm
gonna be looking at the original
objective function as it was published
in Goodfellows paper in 2014 basically
what's happening is that the generator
and the discriminator they are playing a
minimax game because the generator is
trying to create images that actually
fool the discriminator and the
discriminator is always trying to be
right it's trying to see the difference
between real and fake generated images
and so what you can see in the last
function here is that we are minimizing
this objective function for the
generator but we're maximizing it for
the discriminator so let's go a little
bit into detail the discriminator and
network outputs a single scalar value d
of x per image which indicates how
likely it is that this image X is
fact a real image coming from the
dataset it does the same for generated
images you know the generated images are
G of Z so Z here is the noise vector and
G is the generator Network and it
outputs a score you know again the G of
Z of these fake images now while
training we want the discriminator to
recognize real images X as real so we
wanted to output a high value close to
one at the same time we also wanted to
recognize fake images G of Z as being
fake and so therefore outputting a low
value close to zero and this is exactly
what this loss function is doing but
notice that we still call this
unsupervised learning because the labels
kind of come by itself we don't have to
label any of the training data we just
know whether an image came from the data
set or from the generator and at the
same time we also want the generator to
create images of which the discriminator
actually thinks that they might be real
images so the generator is trying to
create images that fool this
discriminator into thinking that those
images are actually real even though
they were generated by the generator and
notice that this first part of the loss
function doesn't really depend on the
parameters of the generator so when
we're optimizing the generator the only
thing we have to optimize for is that
second part of the objective function
and again every time we're calculating
this objective function we are going to
minimize it with respect to the
generator parameters and we're going to
maximize it with respect to the
parameters of our discriminator and if
we then put this objective function into
a concrete algorithm this is what we get
okay so at every training step of the
algorithm we'll start with two things we
sample a batch of random noise vectors
and a batch of images from the data set
and we're then going to use the
objective function that we just saw in
order to update the parameters of the
discriminator by doing gradient ascent
with respect to its parameters
importantly while we're updating the
discriminator the generator network
itself is fixed so we're not changing
anything at
generator part when we're updating the
discriminator once we've updated the
discriminator for a couple of time steps
we then freeze the weights of the
discriminator and we go to you know
another part where we actually train the
generator and notice here that we
resample a new batch of random noise
vectors we generate images with them and
then we apply gradient descent on that
second part of the objective function in
order to update the parameters of the
generator
it will that is the fool out with an
hour in practice you know there are a
few additional tricks that you can apply
to make sure that this objective
function actually converges nicely and
smoothly because it tends to be a little
bit unstable in the exact form that
we've just seen in any case nowadays we
have a wide variety of objective
functions that people use to train these
gans but all of them are built on the
same core idea that we just saw in the
algorithm if you want to get a little
bit of an overview of all these
different flavors I'd really recommend
to check out this medium blog post by
under hiding hi it's really good and it
gives you a nice overview of this entire
Gann landscape so before we start
actually messing around with some real
images I first want to introduce two
final ideas that we're going to be using
in our generative model the first one is
the progressive growing of the layers in
your generative model this was an idea
published by nvidia in their paper
called progressive growing of gaps and
the idea is in fact not that difficult
either you basically start with a
generative model that generates very
very small images of super low
resolution and at the same time the
discriminator also gets to discriminate
between very low resolution images this
makes the entire process actually super
simple so this network is very stable
and it converges quickly once that
network has stabilized you then simply
add an additional layer to both the
generator and the discriminator
architecture which works at a slightly
higher resolution and you keep on
training there's a few additional tricks
where instead of just adding this layer
one shot
you basically do it gradually by
blending the previous layer towards the
higher resolution one but in practice
this is what happens your generator
starts by generating very low resolution
images and the discriminator
discriminates them and then during the
training process you gradually scale up
the resolution of the images in your
training pipeline the second very
influential paper by Nvidia in the
generative model landscape was a model
architecture called style gap and in
fact style gain is the model that we're
going to be using to manipulate our
images so traditionally what happens is
that you take a generator Architecture
and it gets a random noise sample as an
input you feed that noise sample through
a whole bunch of up sampling and
convolutional layers until you get an
image what the style gain generator does
is slightly different first it has a
mapping network and this mapping network
takes the noise vector Z and transforms
it into a different vector called W and
the important thing here is that the W
vector doesn't have to be Gaussian
anymore the distribution of those w's
can be whatever the generator wants it
to be then the actual generator
architecture doesn't start from a random
noise vector anymore it starts from a
constant vector and this constant vector
is actually optimized during training so
it's kind of like a seed a fixed seed in
the beginning of the first layer of the
generator architecture but the actual
numbers of that seed the values of that
vector will they're constant but they're
optimized during the training process
finally the output of the mapping layer
W is plugged into multiple layers of the
generative architecture using a blending
layer called a DES in and during
training also we add noise to these
parameters and for people wondering on
why you would actually use a mapping
layer like this well imagine that you
have a data set right and imagine we
look at two properties we look at gender
and we look at facial hair right so we
have male and female and we have beard
and no beard well in most image data
sets of P
well you will find very little women
that have beards so in other words our
data distribution has a gap there and if
we're sampling from a Gaussian
distribution
well that distribution is uniform so it
doesn't have any gaps and so this is
essentially what this mapping network
allows you to do it allows you to sample
from a uniform distribution
but then warp that distribution in such
a way that you can have gaps for example
where there are no actual images and the
idea is that if this warping of the
space is already done by the mapping
network right so your W vector is
already in a good shape then your actual
generator who takes that vector and
turns it into an image has a much
simpler job of doing that because the
relationship between images and the
input vectors is more one-to-one it
doesn't have any gaps or strange
distortions that it has to learn all
right so that is the style gun generator
architecture and so in the style game
paper they apply this generative
architecture you know which starts from
a constant and uses a mapping layer but
they also use the progressively growing
of the layers and with those two tricks
combined they were able to create a very
powerful gun that was able to produce
incredibly realistic images all right so
now that we've seen a little bit of the
prerequisites it's time to actually go
into our ipython notebook and start
playing with the style game model
ourselves okay so the general principle
that we're gonna leverage here is that
when you train a generative model the
latent space usually learns the
underlying structure of your data set
and again that structure is learned
fully unsupervised by the generative
model because we're not using any labels
in the data set so how can we leverage
this structure well the core idea is
that instead of manipulating images in
the pixel domain which is really
difficult and very complicated we're
gonna manipulate images in the latent
space of that generative model and so in
order to do this starting from any given
image
we're gonna have to find a way to find a
query image inside the latent space of
the generator so more specifically let's
say that we start with this image of
Barack Obama the question is well how
can we find the latent vector Z such
that if we send Z through the generator
we get this image of Barack Obama that's
the first problem we're gonna have to
solve
you could try randomly sampling a whole
bunch of these latent vectors and see
which one is closest but that's gonna
take a really long time we're gonna need
a better approach so one of the most
straightforward things that you could
try is you know given the fact that this
generative model is a fully
differentiable neural network well you
can basically send gradients through it
so you could basically randomly start
from any latent vector Z you generate a
random image but then you compare that
image to the query image of Barack Obama
and you could define a simple loss
function let's say the pixel by pixel
difference you know the l2 difference
between these two images and you can do
gradient descent not on the image but
you send your gradients through this
generator model and you actually update
the latent vector Z at the beginning of
your generator and so by applying
gradient descent on this l2 pixel loss
we could in theory find the optimal
latent vector Z that gives us a good
image of Barack Obama unfortunately this
doesn't really work the l2 optimization
objective is going to start going in the
direction of Barack Obama but before
before it gets there it's gonna get
stuck in a very bad local minimum of an
image that doesn't look at all like
Barack Obama and once we're in that well
the optimization objective simply can't
get out anymore
so l2 optimization directly in the pixel
space doesn't work we're going to need a
different approach and this different
approach is something we've seen a lot
of different machine learning
applications it's the idea that you can
use a pre trained image classifier as a
lens to look at your pixels so rather
than optimizing our l2 law
directly in the pixel space we're gonna
send both the output of our generator
and the query image through a
pre-trained vgg network that was trained
to classify image net images but instead
of actually going all the way to the
last layer onto the classification we're
gonna cut off the head of that network
and we're gonna simply extract a feature
vector somewhere inside the last fully
connected layers of that classifier so
we send these images through the pre
trained classifier we extract a feature
vector at some of the last fully
connected layers in the network and this
gives us a high-level semantic
representation of what is in the image
and it turns out that if we actually do
gradient descent on this feature vector
rather than on the pixels of the image
or approach does work to give you an
idea of what that looks like here's a
small video of an optimization process
on three query images below and the top
images they start from the average face
in the style game space and then start
going towards the query images in the
bottom now there is one final problem
with this approach and that is that this
is actually really really slow it takes
a very long time for the optimizer to
actually find a good latent code I
wonder if there's a way to make a really
good guess of the starting point where
we start our search in the latent space
so with that idea why don't we make a
data set
first we'll sample a whole bunch of
random vectors we'll send them through
the generator and will generate faces
and once we have that data set we can
train a resonant to go from the images
to their respective label code that's
pretty clever
right and so in the repo you'll be using
in a notebook there is already a pre
trained ResNet like this so you can just
use it out of the box so here's what our
pipeline currently looks like we take a
query image we send it through the
residual Network and this network gives
us an image
estimate of the latent space vector in
the stallion Network we then take that
latent vector we send it through the
generator which gives us an image on
this image we apply a pre trained vgg
Network in order to extract features
from it and we do the same thing for our
query image of Barack Obama and then in
that feature space we start doing
gradient descent right we minimize that
l2 distance in this feature space and we
send those gradients through the
generator model all the way back into
our latent code and importantly during
this optimization process the generator
weights itself are completely fixed the
only thing we're updating is the latent
code at the input of our generator and
now in this optimization process there's
a lot of different things that you can
tweak for example which specific layer
of the vgg network are you using as that
semantic feature vector or for example
are we applying a mask to the face such
that only pixels within the face region
are actually used to compute that l2
difference and we can even add a penalty
on the latent code that we're optimizing
such that it doesn't move too far away
from the concept of a face according to
the style gain Network because as it
turns out you can use this process to
find any image you want inside the style
gain Network even a style gun trained on
faces well by doing this this approach
you could basically find a car inside
the latent space of style gap but the
problem is that the vector which gives
you a car is going to be very far away
from that Gaussian distribution that we
actually started from and so if we later
want to start manipulating this face
it's gonna be a really good idea to make
sure that whatever latent vector we're
gonna find is going to be similar to the
concept of a face inside this style gain
Network okay so here's the entire
process into it we start with a query
image we send it through the ResNet and
we
estimate and then we do this latent
space optimization until we finally get
our optimized image which is as close as
possible to the query image that we
started from here's three additional
videos of that process in action on
Albert Einstein emilia clark and barack
obama okay so now that we have the
latent code which gives us our query
image or at least something very close
to it what do we do now
well now it's time to play but in order
to play with the latent space we need
another data set because what we want to
do here basically is we want to start
messing with specific attributes of
those faces things like age gender
smiling glasses all of those attributes
that we kind of know are important for
how a face actually looks and so again
we're gonna randomly sample a whole
bunch of these latent vectors we're
gonna send them through the generator
get our faces and then we're gonna apply
a pre trained classifier that was
trained to recognize a whole bunch of
these attributes and if you wanted to
you could hand label these images with
any kind of attribute that you care
about okay so now that we have all of
those labels for the faces what do we do
with them well basically if you look at
the style guide latent space this is a
512 dimensional space so it's very
complicated and what we really care
about is how a certain direction in that
latent space changes the face that comes
out of the generative model so with the
data set that we just created we can
basically put all of those faces you
know at their respective locations and
we can start looking at all of the
attributes that we've collected and all
of those attributes are quite well
separable by a relatively simple linear
hyperplane in that latent space and so
once we found that hyperplane if we take
the normal with respect to that
hyperplane well this direction in the
latent space basically tells us how can
I make a face look more female because
the only thing I have to do now
is I take my query image I find its
latent space vector and then from that
point in latent space I start walking in
the direction of you know what makes a
face more female and so in the ipython
notebook you will see that in the repo
we're using a whole bunch of these
latent space directions have already
been predefined for you if you want
there is code available to train your
own living space directions on any
attribute that you care about but
they're the ones that are already there
are kind of fun to play with and so with
all of that done I think it's time for
you to start playing with style gap
thank you very much for watching don't
forget to subscribe follow me on Twitter
and support me on patreon and I hope to
see you again in another episode of
archiving sites
[Music]